We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2 1 9 2.
David P..
Here is a caller who has an opinion about
why progressives keep losing.
Let's take a listen.
Hey, David, I think progressives figure out
why they keep losing this, their arrogance.
They keep talking like they think that their
policies are so popular.
And that is completely impossible for voters
to not like them.
And also, Bernie.
But if you keep going into elections with
this, I'm going to knock down the apple.
I'm going to fire everybody.
And you're not willing to actually work with
the existing system like A.L.S. is starting
to realize she has to do.
You're never going to win.
So in my opinion, I don't think her dresses
are ever going to win or have any type of
power in this country.
And so they learn to grow up.
I for the most part, I mean, you guys know
my analysis has been pretty similar to what
that caller says, and I believe indeed progressives
need to come to some of these realizations.
The entire Democratic electorate is not as
progressive as we would like them to be.
And every time I say that, people say no.
But David, everybody loves Medicare for all
you've got to look you have to look more deeply
at those Medicare for all polls.
And when you actually provide more information
about Medicare for all supportfor it does
go down.
I'm not saying it is net unpopular, but support
is low were than many progressives want to
believe.
Bernie is not as likable as some progressives
believe him to be.
And again, you can get mad at me and say I'm
just wrong.
But you know, the two and a half million vote
deficit that Bernie is now suffering at the
hands of Joe Biden.
It is not a glitch.
It is not any of the things that a lot of
people are writing to me about.
And I want to win.
Okay.
And so we need to come to these realizations
if we all want to win.
We'll keep talking about this.
We've got a great bonus show coming up for
you today.
Remember tomorrow, April 9?
One day membership bomb.
You will be notified if you are on my mailing
list at 2:00 p.m. Eastern of a massive membership
special.
We are trying to recover some of the lost
memberships as a result of Corona virus.
Sign up for my newsletter at David Pakman
dot com, 2:00 p.m. Eastern tomorrow.
You will get a very special email.
A very special email.
And I look forward to joining you.
First to you joining me, rather, and produce
the Pats on today's bonus show in just mere
minutes.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.